they say that when you first open a can
of surstromming it's one of the worst
smells in the world let's not do it then
worst gag reflex I'm definitely gonna
heat it's one of the worst things I've
ever smelled in my life
and I can't wait to get out of here I
smelled this from outside the building I
don't see how you can eat this indoors
there's a lot of terrible smells in
there it's like fish baby diaper cheese
EURion the fruit in bed body smells like
foreskin and all these things got
together and they were like hey let's
hang out like we regret like it's not
regret it's weird because you smell it
at first and you know like oh that's bad
like a national park bathroom that
somebody just dumped a bunch of dog food
then another smell kicks in you know oh
that really smells bad no it's not what
Duke it smells like poop then another
one kicks in you're like I'm done oh
yeah I can taste it already the ten
looks like it's left over from World War
it's here honestly
holy [ __ ] I think it's just in a soup of
its own fermentation looks like a booger
it's dripping gray juice this doesn't
look like a real color vomit it looks
like when you walk by a sewer muck and
bacteria that is congealed taking it out
and putting on inflate and intensified
the smell is anyone to eat in this
actually nope I'm not doing it sorry
guys you got to draw the line somewhere
there's worse it's worse than you think
it's gonna be it does not taste even a
quarter as bad as it smells it tastes
very briny and extremely salty you know
I still don't want to eat more of it I
kind of just want to get out of this
right I can imagine this probably tastes
better with side dishes or maybe rough
up in something what the [ __ ] is this
and where is it from and how do I never
have this again scratch that off the
bucket list I feel like the smell is so
overwhelming that is informing my taste
buds to not like it do I have to swallow
it no no I don't want it it's kind of a
really clean fish taste in my mouth at
this point but at the very beginning it
was I don't even know what that taste
was why is it Harry and there are
definitely bones in it should I stick
this whole thing in my mouth how could
this be more heinous it is the worst
thing I've ever eaten the worst thing
I've ever smelled or put in my mouth and
I am not exaggerating that was the
weirdest things in the world of art book
Oh
the coolest thing about this is that
it's pretty badass if you enjoy it and
eat it I mean not many people in the
world I think could stomach this yeah my
final thought is that I never want to
have this so let's close it and close
this chapter on our lives together it's
something that's culturally sensitive
and people should respect that someone
out there eats this and enjoys it
they must have very very
access to their sense of smell because
it is the worst food I have ever smelled